catherine deneuve vous avez derrière
vous déjà une carrière très importante
un palmarès pour un peu une expression
sportif chirac l'eau de mer est brillant
vous n'avez jamais travaillé avec claude
lelouch
ah non alors racontez moi ce qui se
passe quelque chose sur sur le plateau
de lelouch qui fait que c'est un petit
peu différent parce que tous les
comédiens qu'il rejoigne ça tourne avec
claude me disant peut pas t'expliquer
mais c'est pas pareil c'est très
différent
je sais pas si je vais faire mieux que
essayé d'expliquer mais qu'il est
certain c'est que j'ai rarement vu un
plateau sur lequel quand il y avait une
difficulté disons pour un acteur tout
tous les efforts se concentrent sur lui
je veux dire par là que un acteur vit
vraiment sur un film de claude et je
crois que il faut qu'il soit vraiment
très en forme il est très informé qu'il
a beaucoup à donner
je crois qu'il aura beaucoup mais il
faut être vraiment très en forme c'est
pas c'est pas un combat c'est pas
vraiment un sport mais je crois que
claude attend beaucoup parce qu'il se
passe beaucoup de choses sur son plateau
parce que 80 ans aux îles et enfants de
tout le temps il devrait tourner 24
heures sur 24
moi j'aime bien cette idée qu'on peut il
peut se passer beaucoup de choses mais
ce qui est formidable c'est d'abord la
liberté et la liberté mais c'est vrai
que c'est quelque chose à double
tranchant alors il faut il faut savoir
la prendre et l'utiliser parce qu'il
faut savoir qu'il ya quelqu'un qui sera
là pour filmer tout en tournant
[Musique]